[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: To answer your question, the Internet of Things
is when we connect up everyday physical things to the internet.
Yes, even things like shoes.
These things can give us information that can be used to improve your life
or your business or the environment.
Well, yes.
Your boot can tell us things about you, or it, or the places you've walked,
and where you are right now.
It's going to be another Industrial Revolution.
You'd better get ready.
Not a bad revolution, but like when computers
arrived and changed everything.
The Internet of Things means the internet doesn't just
collect and distribute information.
It can also feel and intelligently respond.
What were you looking for?
You can't see the internet of things working.
Ah, your boot.
You think your boot has connected to the internet and booked itself a holiday.
No, that's not how it works.
Though, if you'd been working too hard, your shoe
could send data to the internet cloud, where it would be analyzed,
and then a message would be sent to your boss
to say that it was time for you to have a holiday.
Yeah, it's pretty good, isn't it?